[Music]
so technology is advancing
really rapidly and at some point a lot
of scientists are
saying that at some point we might all
be cyborgs i mean there are already
cyborgs technically
people say the fact that we have iphones
or phones like that can do what they do
now it's like we are cyborgs because we
never part ways with our phone anymore
that's what elon musk is saying this is
like a
brain yeah he says we are cyborgs it's
just our bandwidth is limited by our
thumbs right now because this is how we
access
we got to put this inside of ourselves
no that's a mark at a base well hold on
so the
like people that have like for example
prosthetics like they're considered
cyborg oh yeah
so prosthetics are also kind of like
considered
cyborg territory wait wait are all those
prosthetics though like technological
in that they have like a pick with a
pump i'm a cyborg
you have your body part of like with
machine machine and your flesh yes yep
i think robotic dick you could kind of
classify that but to be a real cyborg
it would have to be like you need the
functions like stuff to keep you alive
right so which brings me to this guy
robocop peter scott morgan
yeah three first names never trust and
he's not a hillbilly
unless they're a lawyer oh that's the
only time no but usually that's multiple
people
oh that's how it works they end up
creating a practice
yeah peter scott and morgan so larry h
and parker came together oh he's just
one guy
the brother of triple h
that was [ __ ] funny it really cracked
me up okay so
anyway uh doc he's a doctor by the way
he's a scientist
and so back in 2017 he got diagnosed
with
a motor neuron disease which is the same
incurable condition that killed stephen
hawking
oh or how steve would say stephen
hawkings he's pretty much considering
himself as a
as a science experiment guinea pig yeah
like a guinea pig because he's
trying to become the world's first
full-fledged
cyborg that's insane yeah that's what
tyson died of too oh
cyborg no the motor like neurotogenesis
where it's like
it's slowly from his rear so his mind
was sharp
and his front legs were sharp but first
it was like he can't
move his tail then he can't control his
butt then he can't really control even
his stomach
so then now he doesn't even know when
he's hungry when he really is very
hungry but he doesn't know that he's
hungry
yeah and it was just like that is how it
affects you yeah in the mood and it
starts moving up up up yeah it moves up
this way too
yeah so for him why doesn't it go this
way
you just died first thing you would die
your brain your head's dead but your
[ __ ] legs will break dancing in the
back
it's like uh like a chicken oh my gosh
it's all tap dancing and [ __ ] yeah like
onward
like onward it was just the dad's feet
oh yeah um
yeah i mean just walking would have been
fine you know
[Laughter]
only the toes though because that's like
the last remaining
why is tap dancing so funny it's time
dude i was like when i was a kid i
thought that was the sickest [ __ ] ever
and that was cool and every time i would
go to payless i would always try on the
tap dancing shoes they had tap dancing
shoes yes
and i always begged my mom to buy them
when her parents died from river dancing
do you remember that
i don't remember that you were dancing
too crazy and then superstar this one
yeah this one her parents died like that
that's why the grandma was against
performance uh why does it sound so
familiar
i gotta watch that movie again this is
the only thing i remember yeah that's it
you could tell legend which generation
yeah from that okay
anyway back to peter here so i have a i
have a
a video for you guys why did she do that
we're back to her all right shannon i
don't know i thought it was funny but
me too it was never answered
the the scene where she was making out
with the tree and it was so passionate
oh yeah
i was like i remember being a little
girl getting like turned up barney and
[ __ ] i'm like
why is this tree weird yeah yeah the
thing for trees huh it wasn't the thing
for trees is how passionate she was
before i wear a tree costume tonight
you're gonna be in bed with like just a
bunch of bars now i'm gonna start
cosplaying as a tree
and then mart's gonna be like casey oh
no
no no
retracting that statement
and i'm gonna be like are you i'll be on
another tree already and i look at casey
whoa i never seen my friend this week
this tree over here that was like thank
you thank you guys
there was another guy in the costume
yeah he was just trying to be a tree
it was trying to pick a tree tree god
damn it
all right but anyway so back to this so
i have a trailer
uh a trailer a truck of peter
so they're doing this this show in the
uk
around him and how he's trying to be a
cyborg and stuff so here we go that's
insane a petri ready
yo this an incredible journey of one
scientist
i intend to be a human guinea pig
diagnosed to neuron disease he
transforms himself
[Music]
he's on a mission to reclaim his quality
of life happy anniversary darling
you can't help but be impressed oh man
he wants to take control
so you could slowly see that he's losing
yeah how much his body's failing himself
insane because he could use this part
like his upper body but then
some parts yeah so the procedure that he
said this is my new interface is because
he
actually got uh like a colossal or
hollowness colonoscopy bag yeah
colonoscopy
yes i think that's how you say it it's
uh so he he also did
he did a feeding tube directly into his
stomach a catheter into his bladder and
a cold
colostomy colostomy bag for me
bag in his colon so that means he
doesn't have to eat and or like
you know now he can get fed by that
feeding tube
because slowly he's going to lose the
the motor skill or whatever it's called
like for the digestive tract
it's so crazy that well maybe just
because he's a scientist and doctor that
he's able to like know about these
things and do it but he seems so like
passionate and happy that he's very
passionate yeah because then that could
eventually help so many more people and
that's true their lives exactly i
thought that was stephen hawking for a
minute
like a younger one that looked like him
yeah
i feel like that once that thing starts
taking over your body like
so you lose the muscle everyone kind of
starts having those similar features
about themselves
yeah because he didn't look like that
when he was young you're getting numb
from like ground up so then he's gonna
be robo man
well so here's the thing so he also
decided to go under to go
undergo a laryndectomy laryngectomy
and so that's to separate his esophagus
and trachea
and so that is to prevent saliva from
running into his lungs
as the paralysis continues to move up
his body towards his chest and his
throat
but that means that he will be losing
his his voice his voice yeah and
for other people who have suffered from
this they said that
losing your voice is the most
um like the hard the hardest thing it's
how do you communicate
exactly it's like you you no longer feel
like a person that's what makes you
feel like really well they're saying
that that's what makes them feel the
most disabled is not being able
to communicate well stephen hawking was
able to use his like
hand and it got to like one thing and
then it was his eyes huh
well and then after the eyes it was
something with the brain but when he was
communicating
wasn't it like because he was using his
eyes or something and then he would
the sound would come out right so then
the doctor who helped him
finalize it to the most like recent form
of his
his ability to communicate that's the
same doctor that he has enlisted into
helping him
come up with a technology so pretty much
is
they're creating this this ai
to provide full and instant responses
so he can communicate rather than typing
out individual letters
using a gaze tracker what if it said the
wrong thing and it's like no no that's
not what i wanted to say
it autocorrected yourself yeah they
actually give him a female voice
like siri no he's actually so before
losing his voice
he has spent so much time recording his
voice saying different
words saying different like syllables
whatever it is and
you say all the bad words too just to
make sure they get it right probably
because you know like stephen hawking
like
he pretty much has the same voice of a
speaking spell so then whenever i hear
that i'm like oh that's stephen hawking
right
and then like if the technology didn't
change it would have sound the same
but then now he's gonna have
customization do you feel like
at this point though you would also like
even though you don't understand you
just speak a bunch of like different
languages
just sound wise and then the computer's
gonna do it right for you anyway well
it's hard because like siri can pretty
much say a lot of things yes
but you tell her to say nadeem she
doesn't say no to him like nadeem
nate i'm like yeah like this guy can
speak in his own words properly but then
you're like oh my name is the team he's
like nadeem and like no it's the theme
he goes
maybe well he can't pronounce that so
it's like
it's like learning new words can you do
that yeah
so then that like this like this entire
case is really
highlighting how like how do we define
what it means to be human then at this
point
because if an a.i is doing the speaking
the interaction
for him then it's not really him
necessarily but he's trying to put the
most
of himself into this ai and into
everything else that he's doing in his
body so it's just really blurring the
line
at some point the this ai is going to
take over
the consciousness well it's not taking
over the consciousness is more like
providing like
being able to understand how peter would
respond
to a question and answering as if like
this is how peter would answer
with this ai trying to be peter are you
sure it's that way
that's how they explain it or is it um
like stephen hawking's where it's still
his voice but um he's telling you what
to say because he can't physically speak
yeah it's it's along the lines of that
so it's still not like ai
well they're calling it an ai though
because they're they are
other functions that are algorithm of
some sort of like this is how peter's
brain
works this is how he would respond even
though like
i don't know exactly but the his brain
is still like
the main intention and driver yeah so so
is it
is it like when you ask like syria or
alexa or something like that for
information then they technically
have to either search google or search
blah blah so this ai is kind of like a
filter that has to like ask his brain
what he wants to say
right like that when it gets like
addressed right like there's probably
some sort of like you have to say his
name for its function
hey peter that's insane hello peter
because i still feel like it's going to
be him
it's the brain his brain is still the
human part of him right even if he's 100
robot
well that's the thing he's eventually
trying to get to the point where he can
transfer his entire like
consciousness and all that stuff into a
machine so he could continue to live
yeah that would be i would do that it
would be like transcendent
i would want to would looks a little bit
crazy to be like
totally like in the digital space true
because
in that same scenario if he becomes
fully like cyborg or something and then
he can like
upload himself into any into that
computer the thing is do because
whenever i hear that theory where it's
like if once ai can go
why would they not want to take over
exactly or they're gonna notice that
humans are the [ __ ] virus and then
get rid of us because we're the ones
causing the earth to be
[ __ ] yeah oh cancel cultures catching up
i'll just turn off this and i'll go
to my mud hut bye bye
[Music]
you